now we will turn our full focus to the
United States we are privileged to have
with us four members of President
Obama's Advisory Council on financial
capability as we will hear they bring a
rich depth of experience I am now
pleased to introduce the moderator for
this panel
Janet Bodnar as the editor of
Kiplinger's Personal Finance magazine
Janet's job is to help her readers
manage their money wisely in addition to
overseeing the men of magazine janet has
written extensively about a wide range
of topics on investing personal finance
and the economy janet is also a
nationally recognized author and expert
in the field of family finances her
latest book is money smart women
everything you need to know to achieve a
lifetime of financial security
Janet's money smart kids column appears
regularly in Kiplinger's and she has
appeared on Oprah the Today Show Good
Morning America CBS FOX CNN CNBC and PBS
with the Sterling credentials Janet I
will turn it over to you well speaking
of sterling credentials we have a panel
full of shining credentials sitting up
here I'm going to introduce each of them
briefly and we're going to move right
into some very interesting questions
some of which grew out of the initial
panel the first panel which is very
interesting
others are specialties of these folks up
here and others have been submitted to
us by members of the audience and
they're very curious to know certain
things and so we're gonna get right in
just a midi gritty personal finance
stuff and the first person who's going
to be talking to you at the end here is
Cary Schwab Pomerance again all of these
people are members of the President's
Council on financial capability so
they're all very financially capable and
in their day jobs they have very
financially capable day jobs Cary is the
head of the president of the Charles
Schwab foundation and has a great
interest in financial literacy and
children in money
and then we have Rick Ketchum who's the
chairman of FINRA the Financial Industry
Regulatory Authority and so he's got a
lot of uh a lot of financial stuff in
his purview and here we have Ted Beck
who is the head of Neifi the National
Endowment for financial education a
group that has financial tools available
to teachers out there to teach literally
hundreds of thousands of kids all about
the things that we've been talking about
today and at the end is Roland our Tiago
also known as our dr tiago he says i can
call him artie and he is actually
president of the defense credit union
counsel and he his particular interest
on the President's Council of an ad for
financial capability is access for
consumers who are unbanked or perhaps
lower income consumers who aren't part
of the financial system so those are the
experts that we have up here today and I
wanted to start I wanted to start with
with Rick there was some discussion in
the first panel about the role of a
research and and and how what how this
can play to our concerns about financial
literacy but you and your group in
conjunction with the the President's
Council have actually been involved in a
lot of work on financial literacy a lot
of research and you've done a lot of
studies on this so tell us what we found
out sort of to set a baseline what do we
know about the financial capability of
children and adults sure Janet I think a
key part and Ted we'll talk a little bit
more about really the vision and where
we're going with the research and
evaluation subcommittee of the the
council but the first thing is to
understand what we don't know and really
where the greatest challenges are and
what those challenges are and and that
was what we tried to do from the
standpoint of FINRA investor Education
Foundation working with the Department
of Treasury working with the earlier
president's Advisory Council to put
together three discreet surveys all
looking at financial county capability
the first a national survey done by
telephone the second a state-by-state
survey to look at differences across the
country and the third of military survey
to look at the particular challenges and
exposures with respect to there are key
people in the military to get a basic
understanding better on
standing of the financial capabilities
of adults in the United States and the
initial findings are are daunting and I
think valuable as a starting point and
it really is a starting point is a key
thing about this capability is to
provide the basis for for additional
research studies that can drill in on
the information nearly 49% of the
persons being surveyed said they had
difficulty just covering their monthly
expenses now these are all I mean these
are all adults that were these are all
adults these are all adults indeed
twelve percent said that their host
outside expenses over the past year were
greater than their income
well another 36% said that their
household expenses were about equal to
income fewer than half fewer than 50%
had a rainy day fund of any sort that
would provide enough savings to cover
expenses for three months in case of
sickness job loss or other emergency
only 42 percent said that they had tried
to figure out how much that they needed
to save for retirement years even maybe
more terrifying only half of Americans
over the age of 45 had begun the process
of figuring out how much they need in
retirement and 12% reported that they
had neither a checking or savings
account if you will the fundamental core
unbanked that that created additional
set of challenges we put all this
information not only available but but
on wwu s financial capability org to
basically allow it as a source for
researchers to really take it and move
it farther to begin the process of
really being able to drill in and see
what where our greatest problems are and
how we can think a little bit
differently about them mm-hmm yes and I
asked Ted at the moment since you're
also on the research committee as far as
the the President's Council on financial
capability would you like to add
anything to anything that Ric has said
especially as it regards younger people
he's talked about the adult population
because it too encouraging what about
the younger population well I think
there's been a couple of very positive
trends and research of my organization's
heavily involved in the research
community and there have been a few
things that have been happening over the
last few years that I think are very
encouraging
the whole personality of research has
changed and I think a couple of the key
things are we're looking very much at
behavior we've I think come to the
conclusion we're not all going to be
perfect so we have to understand where
people are coming from so the concept of
looking at behavior and behavioral
economics is I think have been a very
positive factor the second thing is
application research is now being linked
to application and doing the testing
that the first panel talked about so
we're not only coming up with some ideas
but we're testing them out in the
community and try to figure out what we
can bring back that applies to a broader
part of the community and I think the
last thing and this may be the most
important is evaluation many of the
research projects many of the
initiatives done non elation but very
much with the youth population we feel
good about it but we haven't done a very
vigorous evaluation of the effectiveness
now that's one thing that I'm very
pleased to say is changing people are
now really trying to figure out what
works and how they could be applied more
broadly we're gonna get back to that a
little bit later it's actually that was
one of the questions that we got from
our from our audience but I do want to
finish up with some of the opening
questions for the panelists just to
introduce you to them now Carrie you
wanted you are on the partnerships in
your particular interest on the
President's Council counselors in
partnerships and I obviously and you're
part of the your you you stand in both
both realms here you're part of the
private sector and you're also part of
the government Council so how do those
two mesh well I was gonna say that you
know if you think about it I think about
it in the private sector and then also
in the public sector where resources are
slim
and so I'm a big believer that we have
to be creative and we have to be scrappy
you know with making more change or more
efficient change in our society in
particular with financial literacy and I
think that's really where the government
can partner with the private sector the
nonprofit sector and and we can we can
really make change now you know as it
relates to financial literacy you know
my belief and I know my colleagues here
also feel the same way if there's a
plethora of financial curriculum out
there you know some absolutely wonderful
of course the visa program but some not
so good but the bottom line is is so
it's not that we need more curriculum
what we need is more distribution
channels where we have constituents who
have a sense of trust with the
organization's that they're working with
so for example at Charles Schwab become
because a private you know private
nonprofit relationship over the last
eight years I've overseen a partnership
with Boys and Girls Club it's the
largest youth agency in the United
States serving up to five million kids
and four thousand clubs and so we took
swabs financial acumen combined it with
their you know distribution channel of
kids and their ability to engage kids
and we've created this after-school
financial education program and we've
seen that it absolutely works and that
we are changing behaviors so I think
partnerships is is critical you know
we're seeing it actually with you know
Michelle Obama's work on child obesity
where you can bring all avenues of
society together to make a change and
that's where I think where we could be
successful with in the government and
the private sector working together I
can just add a little on that because I
think the point is so critical an
example of a great effort of government
led partnership that both the FINRA
investor Education Foundation been
involved with and already has been
involved with respect to the defense
credit union has been Department of
Defense effort on standpoint of
financial readiness campaign first I
think it's a great example because it's
a classic example when an organization
determines something is fundamental to
their basic vision and strategy and the
Defense Department recognizing the
challenges of young adults coming in
often with a range of education the rest
to find this is fundamental to the
morale issue from the standpoint of the
military they are they they involve 27
different organizations under the
campaign I from our standpoint we work
closely to both to get at the point
Karrie mate which is it's great to have
content tent it's all about delivery and
it particularly helpful in delivery if
you have somebody like the military who
can Pitt can put butts in seats which is
they're very effective but beyond that
the military has another unique
advantage that that's somewhat different
and that is the the chronic problems
from the standpoint of underemployment
with respect to military spouses because
of the continuing moving challenges of
those spouses and we were able to work
to train those spouses out from a
train-the-trainer standpoint to deliver
a range of financial capability material
and tutoring from that standpoint been
enormous ly accessible and a real great
example of when an organization becomes
focused on something what can be
delivered and I know that already could
speak a little up from the standpoint of
Defense credit union counsel because
they've been really central to all of
this let me if I could then let me just
add one point to that because Rick is
spot-on with that I'm actually the
defense credit union counsel is actually
a chartered member of the Department of
Defense financial readiness campaign and
the success of that campaign has been
because of one work commitment the
department had a commitment from day one
with the troops and their families not
just the soldiers sailors airmen Marines
and corpsman the troops and their
families to ensure that a compact of
some sort was developed and made between
the department in each one of them and
throughout their years they've actually
done a tremendous job since 2003 pulling
it together with fantastic partners such
as nithi who was a partner and obviously
FINRA and the other 25 including
ourselves and my counterpart on the
military bank side of the house but I
think commitment was the very important
key factor here in order to make certain
that it succeeded succeeded what were
you and Rick had alluded earlier to some
research that had been done among
defense you know military personnel what
did you identify as some of the problem
areas with that particular population
and then how does that relate to the
general population especially those who
have
limited access or but even the rest of
us obviously if people even who have
access they're having trouble with
financial literacy or we wouldn't all be
here today right I think if you're
asking me about the Department of
Defense population some of the issues
they're certainly time was the biggest
issue when you stop and think about it
our soldier sailor Airman marine z--
don't actually have the time that's not
their primary function in life that's
not commander's primary function in life
to teach financial education they're
there to train these folks they ensure
that our national security is maintained
so finding the time was a real obstacle
quite honestly and a barrier that they
had to overcome but again back in 2003
the then Undersecretary of defense for
personnel and readiness dr. David Chu
actually came out with a social compact
a compact an agreement of sorts between
the department and every soldier sailor
Airman marine saying we're going to give
you that time we're going to mandate it
during basic training now in in our
general society and in society in
general especially in the area that I'm
looking at quite honestly when it comes
to a unbanked and underbanked time is
critical but I don't think that that's
the biggest issue that we have the
biggest issue that we have I think in
the unbanked under Bank area is a
convenience and B trust certainly income
is a part of that but I think those two
at the top when you look at the military
convenience is always there because
they're in a military installation
they're confined to their quarters to a
certain extent and they have trusted
vetted partners that work with them on a
daily basis such as defense credit
unions that are actually vetted before
they're permitted to be on the military
base and actually partners such as a
nonprofits around here in terms of trust
the military is based on trust and so
two major differences and and I'm hoping
that as we move forward with this
council that we continue to discuss how
do we overcome those two barriers
trusting convenience and the unbanked
underbanked all right have you been
surprised by anything since you've been
working with the under bank unbanked
population am surprised at anything that
you've discovered as far as how they do
or do not get financial services you
know I was surprised at something
actually
one always assumes that the
infrastructure isn't in place and that's
why they don't have access to mainstream
financial institutions but I did read a
research study that was done for the
Brookings Institute and it actually
enlightened me a bit and it suggested
that there was a credit union branch or
a bank branch within one mile of 90% of
the alternative financial providers in
the United States so the infrastructure
is there there but they don't the
infrastructure is there and so you have
to dig one one leg level down and try to
ascertain what is the issue and that's
why I'm suggesting the trust maybe just
carry interesting part there you were
talking about a partnership arrangement
that you had had with the Boys and Girls
Club and one of the things we heard from
the earlier panel it's really I think
this idea of engagement and of young
people older people as well but
certainly young people how do you get
them to sit still and listen to this or
how do you get them interested in this
and entertainment is obviously something
that works but I don't know did you use
entertainment in order to engage those
kids or were there other things I think
that would be a benefit to the teachers
who are listening in anybody who was
involved in financial literacy education
how do you get their minds and hearts
how do you get them well yeah well so
with Boys and Girls Club I mean it's an
after-school program and it's a very
comprehensive program you know it's it's
a lot of people thinking about sports
not just about sports it's about doing
your homework and education it's about
leadership building it's about working
in the community and financial literacy
to be honest with you the money matters
program is the fastest growing program
that they have and you know I'm
convinced and our research shows that
kids do want to learn about money I
think one of the panelists earlier said
their studies show the same thing
actually the parents but kids want to
learn it's fun and so it's John Bryant
you know our Co colleague on the council
oi says is that kids do want to learn
how to make money legally so so you know
we I don't you know there's a little bit
of bribery here and there you know with
some pizza you know but but they but the
Boys and Girls Club really know how to
make any type of program come
alive and again you know bringing
speakers taking them out making games
you know we do have scholarships for the
top kids who embed it in their lives we
actually have a money matters ambassador
we have innovation prizes as well for
clubs who who actually act out the the
material for instance several of them
have little stores so you know
entrepreneur ism is part of the
curriculum and they're learning how to
you know start a business so it's fun
it's fun stuff I I was gonna I just had
one thing too that I you know there's a
we did a research piece that's ongoing
with University of Arizona that kind of
talks about this whole motivation and
how do you make it interesting thing and
we studied to that and are continuing to
study 2,000 young adults who were in
college and we looked to see where they
were having risky behavior and but we
also looked to see those students who
were not demonstrating risky behavior
what were the positive influences that
caused that and they were in order
family where the family would talk about
money and it was okay to bring it up at
the dinner table and get some idea of
you know where does money come from it's
kind of what was talked about earlier
about how many hours you have to work to
buy that thing so first of all families
second having had some education so the
basic tools and third is having had a
part-time job so they can equate that
work of to buy something into how many
hours that they worked so one of the
things I would like to encourage
especially employers out there is find
real part-time jobs for high school
students because that sinks financial
education financial capability home as
much as anything I was just gonna
comment you know Boys and Girls Club
hires a lot of their kids and also our
research does show at Schwab that kids
who have jobs are much more highly to be
are much more likely to be high savers
so there is a correlation between
part-time work and saving and I think if
I had my choice of one thing that I
would want kids to do that is to save
and make it like like in their DNA is
Rosie mansions like
your teeth you just don't even think
about it so I think jobs exactly what
Ted said and also I would like to add in
my I write on the subject of children
and money and my sort of parallel life
Kiplinger's and I often get questions
from kids and one of the most frequently
asked questions by kids is how do I get
a job how do I earn money and this
starts at middle school age so this is
before they can actually go out and you
know get a paying job with that with an
employer in the workplace but they want
to know how they can earn money but and
but it goes into the high school years
they really don't know how to get a job
and they don't know how to manage their
skills or market their skills they don't
think they have any skills you know they
don't have the idea that they could have
a resume and that that resume might
include their academic achievements in
school or extracurricular activities or
the fact that they play on sports teams
they don't really get that and so if
you're a guidance counselor or if you're
a teacher or a parent just telling them
that they really do have skills that
they can market or suggesting to them if
it's an eleven-year-old who can't go out
into the workplace but do I need money
what can I do what are sort of things in
the neighborhood that you as an adult
would pay for you know would you pay for
kids to take your recycling down every
Wednesday night and bring the you know
the bins up on Thursday morning would
you pay for that we should pay for
somebody to water your plants and pick
up your newspapers when you go on
vacation in the summer that sort of
thing is really important and then
transitioning into the high school years
as Ted alluded to when someone in the
audience was applauding if you've got if
you're an employer you think about go to
your local high school to the guidance
counselor there if you've got part-time
positions that you can fill during the
summer
um these kids have skills that probably
you don't even have social media skills
for example computer programming skills
that sort of thing so you know I think
that there's a way to address the again
the partnerships there maybe this in
this case between schools and between
employers I think that's really I would
that would be my two cents because I see
this all the time they don't know how to
earn money and they always want very
easy jobs where they can earn six
hundred dollars in four weeks you know
where can I get this and that's what
they ask you know but that's how they're
thinking think like a kid and I think
it's really important when you're
talking about from there
literacy to do that Ted you were to all
we're talking about thinking like a kid
you were mentioning this some of the
programs that nithi offers actually are
available to reach literally hundreds of
thousands of kids out there right oh yes
we offer several programs but there are
many organizations that are doing very
good work and a lot of them are actually
represented in the audience here so I
don't want to do a big plug for nithi
although I will probably do it
eventually but there's some awfully good
programs out there and there's there's a
common factor in many of them that and
that's the dedicated teacher there isn't
a lot of shelf space very of financial
education in the schools and despite
that our program alone reaches over six
hundred thousand kids a year and we're
just one of many that I think do very
good work and most of that is because a
teacher is taking initiatives and
they're really tried that they're
looking at it and saying these are life
skills that my students need so often
they're sort of sneaking into math or
social sciences we've actually had a
physics and an English teacher come to
some of our teacher training programs so
that they can try to figure out how to
get financial education into their
classroom so I think there's a there's a
really admirable effort being out there
but it's not being supported anywhere as
much as it should be and coordinating
that effort is I think one of the key
things we can do in our positions to
make sure that those teachers are
supported segue into my next question to
you what teachers will often tell you
and if their teachers here they may even
be thinking this is that even they don't
feel comfortable you know dealing with
this subject themselves because they
don't have a specialty in finance
finances financial education or they
don't have the time in our speaking of
time they have so many other demands on
their time as a classroom teacher that
how do I fit this into my day and I'm
presuming that perhaps Neifi some of
your programs would be able to help them
in that regard you would have some
advice for them well I think we have to
take a step back and I apologize I'm a
bit of a research walk so I'm going to
quote some researcher we funded a
research project that really asked the
question about how prepared our teachers
in the middle and high school
areas to teach personal finance this was
a study that was done by eight
universities around the country that the
University of Wisconsin led and the
numbers were disturbing and they
confirmed what we hear from teachers a
lot that there one chapter ahead of
their students 64% of the teachers said
that they did not feel capable or
comfortable teaching their own state
standards and less than 20 percent felt
capable or comfortable in teaching six
key subject areas ranging from savings
to investing to careers and income so
some work needs to be done there now on
a positive factor 89 percent of the
teachers in the same study said they
thought it was important to have
financial education in the schools which
I thought was very interesting to tie it
to the number Byron gave earlier than 85
percent of the teachers are excuse me
parents said this was important so
there's clearly demand out there that
this this be incorporated in the school
system in some way and be that in the
curriculum itself or creative
after-school programs I'm kind of
indifferent on that as long as it's
available and emphasized do you think
one of the things I find to that I like
to tell teachers and parents to kind of
reassure them is that no matter how
little you think you know about money
you always know more than your kids they
are always going to ask very basic
questions I mean I was I attended every
month every April which is Financial
Literacy Month I always make it a point
to go to a school that is or schools
programs that are doing this with kids
to find out what they're doing and one
of the things I found last year I went
to a high school program in the DC area
and one of the things the questions that
the kids were asking is what's the
difference between a checking account
and a savings account I mean they
weren't asking how does the Federal
Reserve work and how does it create
money or qe2 they weren't asking about
things like that they want to know
what's the difference between the
savings and a checking account so even
if you can give them basic knowledge I
think that that is is really a step in
the right direction so you should feel
confident that you actually can teach
kids and teaching them and someone else
alluded to this earlier too small steps
have incredibly big results just now
knowing that in fact a credit card is
not money it's a loan is something
that's important for kids to learn and
that alone can keep them out of trouble
I think that's what your research has
shown as well family discussion even
really makes it makes a big impact right
yeah absolutely and and I think one of
the words you used was continuous which
i think is critical previously I think
our community thought if we could get
somebody and sit them down for a class
that'd be good to go it's like an
inoculation that you're going to know
finance for the rest of your life well
the rules change it's a continuous
process that starts from allowances
through to decisions you make in
retirement and so small bits of
information be it at point of sale that
was talked about earlier as people are
contemplating large transactions just
making sure there's enough information
that's available to them so that it fits
into their time schedule is very
important one of the things we tell
parents is the first time your child
asks you about money don't feel that you
have to sit them down and give them a
two-hour lecture exactly it's like sex
education that's not gonna work so try
it just in little bits and also you
might want to do some homework so you're
actually telling him good advice make a
comment there in terms of the financial
education absolutely it's very important
over the past month I attended to
financial reality fairs I'm not sure if
you're claiming those but they actually
put into practice what they teach in the
classroom and I think that that's
absolutely critical as well you go
through the classroom you go through a
curriculum whether it's a Neifi program
whether it's a credit union for a
reality program MoneySmart program
whatever the case may be and at the end
of the curriculum you go into this huge
auditorium and all of a sudden you have
5 6 7 10 tables set aside and in the end
the youngsters that go through that
whether they're middle aged youngsters
and I attended one last week with middle
age or high school youngsters which was
about four weeks ago on Capitol Hill
they actually receive a piece of paper
that gives them their occupation they
decide what they want to do for a living
and it puts a salary on there and it's a
rude awakening for these youngsters to
realize that they're not really making
$50,000
because Uncle Sam's taking a piece of
that as the state is and so once they
have that that net income then they go
to each table transportation lodging
would want to buy a pet entertainment
auto auto loans if they desire that I
mean they go through all tables and at
the end of the exercise obviously the
key here is to come up with a positive
balance if they don't they go visit a
financial counsellor last week when I
was in New Hampshire and I attended the
middle age school there and the credit
union Museum they actually had high
school students doing the financial
counseling of eighth graders and I tell
you what it was absolutely successful
and they came from the Academy of
Finance there in Manchester New
Hampshire and so these youngsters knew
what they were doing and I thought that
that was excellent any real world I
think you're right already that's been
my observation when I go into the
classroom as well anything that has to
do with the real world is just it just
clicks with them and again small steps
in the world but they can figure out you
know mortgages you know how much a
mortgage payment will be on there much
reduced income after they've paid their
taxes you know they can really learn
this and so again small steps really
work what do you folks think about and I
think Byron mentioned this earlier there
are only a few states that actually
require some form of financial education
in the schools I mean what do you think
how big a difference would that make if
this type of education were required and
then the corollary question is if it's
not going to be required for whatever
reason because it's difficult
politically are there other priorities
you know how can individuals or schools
make a difference maybe if I could start
I think there's a another step that has
to happen first and that's treasurer
rios referenced the national strategy
and the core competencies that we've
been working on with some of the
agencies in Washington first I think we
need to agree on what we want people to
know and then build standards or
recommendations around that then you can
start to track whether it's making a
difference or not in the education
that's being provided so first step is
let's agree with what we want people to
know and this isn't only students this
is this is the entire popular
then you can start to build effective
standards and guidelines so that schools
can start to build against something and
evaluate against something so I think
it's a Tuesday I think it's a very
important thing that we have this in the
schools but I think it's a two step
process that we owe the schools some
guidelines on what we want to achieve
Ted maybe we ought to mention the
financial literacy financial capability
challenge which the President's Council
has sponsored over the last two
administrations it is a thirty five
question test that's administered by
teachers for the kids it actually is
available for kids who are home-schooled
and I actually took the test actually
the original testament and I've been in
the business since 1983 and it was a
pretty hard test and about the average
grade was fifty percent right and under
the new we actually made it a little bit
easier so that kids could feel some
sense of accomplishment but what I
personally really like about this is
that there are so many issues in terms
of getting personal finance in the
schools there's only seven states that
have it and you know you know
everybody's mentioned its teachers don't
you know its teachers don't even know
how to teach it you know we don't even
know how to teach our kids math and
reading right now right we're not even
good at that so so this capability you
know it's a contest again having fun and
games and so we've had at least the
first we've had about a couple hundred
thousand kids go through the program
we've had teachers that are teaching it
before school starts we have one teacher
in Florida that teaches at 7:30 in the
morning and she has she always books up
all the kids can't take it because
there's not enough room and she has
multiple kids who have perfect scores on
this test so so there are other avenues
including you know after-school programs
with Boys and Girls Club that sort of
stuff to get to the kids as long as we
can't you know get it in schools
obviously schools it's the most I think
the would be the most impactful but we
have so many issues going on here but I
wanted to mention that for anybody who
happens to be an education world about
this and there's also scholarships by
the way for the top winners and it's
going on now isn't it I mean going on
right now till
planet week April 8th I think yeah and
this and this is the fur at the high
school level is that yes okay I want to
jump into we have these wonderful
questions that we got from audience
folks in advance of this and some of
them they're all very interesting and
some very provocative and I wanted to
toss these out to our panelists and see
what they think
first of all what is in speak we just
were talking on the subject of age let's
just close that out what's the youngest
age that the government will be
encouraging teaching financial literacy
now the the challenge is for high school
kids but you know how early does Neifi
go down and what about the the what is
the President's Commission think about
this Ted would probably I mean I have my
own personal opinions you know the
government I don't think has made a
statement yeah I'll give a personal
opinion that personal opinion I'm
repeating what I said before but it's a
continuous process you know you start
talking about you know money when you
start at the you know five or six worth
of court allowances but then it goes
throughout your economic life so we're
doing a lot of research right now on
information people need in retirement
because there there are decisions around
their assets are so critical and that's
at all income levels so I think it's a
continuous process with different age
appropriate pieces at each time yes we
can teach how to do a mortgage to a 16
year old they're much more interested in
how do you buy a car so let's make sure
we make it interesting for them we could
make this the driest subject in the
world but we have to be more creative
than that and we have to really put
ourselves in their position and say what
do they want to know maybe to that point
in and of course it's important for the
audience to understand we are talking
individually the committee hasn't
reached conclusions yet and and that's
the beauty the subcommittee is a chance
for us to have those conversation but I
think Ted's point is really important
it's critical to understand that you're
building throughout school and then
beyond that that that that financial
capability and education it has to be a
continuing issue in those critical
moments when decisions are being made
past high school two decisions with
respect to student loans putting aside
credit cards from a college standpoint
and often critical errors without
understanding from the standpoint of
government versus versus private student
loans and the different factors involved
in each end and the the lack of
understanding with respect to career
choices and the and the earning
opportunities on the other side tied to
student loans as you carry on to masters
programs and beyond I to the the savings
issues from a 401k standpoint in early
parts of careers that the rest I think
that's one of the reasons why carry on
are so pleased to be involved in the
partnership side of looking at this and
and trying to provide clearer guidance
of maybe how to effectively either
inspire or create solid partnership
because this only works is if there is
the support for individuals as they go
throughout their life from elementary
school to high school college and then
from the decisions you have to make
throughout your professional career a
party you would mentioned does this tie
into what you said about trust that
there are you know financial
institutions within a mile of most folks
in this country but there are people who
just don't want to they just don't trust
them they've either had a bad experience
with them or there's a language barrier
associated with that in the research
that we've done and in the discussions
that we've had in the financial access
subcommittee we basically identify that
low-income and minorities quite honestly
or the unbanked and the underbanked in
the United States and the Hispanic
population is a great part of that I
want to say it's somewhere in the
neighborhood according to a 2009 FDIC
study I want to say it's about twenty
twenty four percent somewhere in that
vicinity and so it's that trust level
that does how do you bridge that trust
level carries uh what I call the BDR for
the partnership committee here and she's
doing a wonderful job there and I'm a
part I'm a member of that partnership
subcommittee and in my dealings with my
subcommittee I've come to the
realization that partnerships with the
nonprofits in the low-income
neighborhoods are the only way the only
way to bridge that trust to be honest
with you
we actually have a credit union that
that went out to Southeast Washington
opened up a branch there and actually
enlisted the support of 50 that's 5-0
nonprofit organizations to help bring
that community together in Ward 7 and 8
so that they could at least provide some
financial education number one
understanding of the quote unquote
banking system number two and bring them
in to the credit union movement number
three and thus far they have made many
inroads they haven't reached all their
objectives but you can see that the
progress is being made so when you talk
about trust you need to look at the
partnerships that are out there in the
nonprofit world but there is no way that
the government's going to do it on its
own and there's no way that a banking
institution is going to do it on its own
as well another question we got was what
what role does technology play in this I
mean if you're talking about a teachable
moment teaching a teenager when they're
you know getting a car loan or teaching
someone who's about to apply for a
mortgage what role does the web play on
this the Internet I mean is do your
programs factor into this and is this
something where they could go and you
know take 20 questions take a little
tutorial on what they need to know about
applying for a mortgage before they do
it is that something that you're
thinking about any of you it's really
the technology side has just got this
huge opportunity for us NRT and I were
at a meeting last week in Washington
where we saw a new technology
application that was basically using a
system to reward people when they
decided not to make an impulse buy and
that really fits coupling that with core
education I think is really could make
this fun and encouraging and try to make
sure that it gets to people on a
continuous basis so technology is a huge
opportunity for us that we're trying to
make sure we embed in this and actually
our teas access committee has been doing
some great things there we have actually
that's one of our focuses and again
we're still in the discussion phase but
we're looking at the emerging
technologies and even knows it exists
today I sat down with the center for
financial service and innovation which
actually partnered with Neifi on the
hill this past week and actually
showcased that
those innovations and that's what our
subcommittee is looking at we certainly
will make technology a part of this
answer when you look at everybody around
here I can probably ask the question who
doesn't own a cell phone here and I
would suspect that maybe one or two
would raise their hand probably not
everybody here owns a cell phone so you
have to look at those technologies
because I think that again is also going
to be a factor in addressing this issue
mm-hmm well now here's that rather
potentially controversial question
Taiwan Singapore Hong Kong Japan and
even China have strong math education in
their k-12 schools as seen in their test
results guaranteeing I don't know about
guaranteeing but guaranteeing financial
literacy in most Asian countries is it
possible that America's financial crisis
is due to our widespread math illiteracy
anybody want to feel about what I'll
call it some reason if they make math
relevant I'm not sure I totally agree
with yeah but it raised some interesting
points how much of this is math based
and how much is you know not where is
relevant to other curriculum regretfully
there is a strong linkage some work we
did that we looked at financial literacy
and then we went back and this was
primarily in minority communities and
then looked at underlying literacy on
math or the ability to read English and
the linkage between poor financial
literacy scores and poor understanding
of math underneath it was very strong so
the more we strengthen the school system
the easier our jobs gonna be because
people are very intimidated by math do
you know what I carry first you wanted
to say something no I know I was gonna
actually change the subjects just for a
minute for a minute if that's okay um
you know we've been talking a lot about
kids but we've also been men talking
about relevant moments and when to teach
and an area that our subcommittees
working on is well we're looking a lot
of partnerships in ways that we can
really make a big difference and I just
wanted to share a little bit
another you know point of relevancy and
that is workplace financial education
this was an area that the prior council
was working on and so our partnership
committee is carrying on and we find
that this is a huge opportunity you know
if the kids don't learn in school this
you know your first job is when it
really becomes relevant so so workplace
has a huge distribution channel of about
155 million people we talk a lot about
trust our research shows at Schwab that
70% of employees would like to have
financial education given by their
employer another interesting fact about
workplace is that they have historically
been a cultural game-changer so if you
think about it and that's really what
we're talking about changing the culture
about the importance or the you know
taking on this responsibility for
ourselves if you look at sort of the
civil rights and diversity and the way
we interact with one another in the
workplace you know gender differences
ethnic differences whatever those lines
kind of blur in the workplace and so
hopefully the workplace can also change
the culture and the importance of
financial literacy so our our council is
right now looking at some large
partnerships on how to do that how to
engage work corporations and and I could
go on and take the whole rest of the
time but I will just mention one
particular one that I think it's very
interesting is that the New York Stock
Exchange foundation is sponsoring the
creation of a financial literacy
diagnostic for employees in which in
going back to using technology basically
it's being devised by a couple of
professors experts in this area and you
answer probably about six questions
regarding your financial knowledge and
needs and based on your response
education will pop up and then there is
a way for the employer to customize it
so that if you're wanting to buy a home
or open up a 529 account your employer
can say here's
reputable companies that we you know
feel good about so we're i think and in
the new york stock exchange by the way
it's run by michelle green who used to
be the executive director of the council
and and so she's going to make that
available to all the new york stock
exchange members which i think there's
thousands right rick and and and i said
to her we're also partnering with the
federal agencies as well and i said do
you think this diagnostic could be
available for the fet and she said ah I
don't see why not
so again this is sort of you know
partnership people kind of wanting to
jump in make a difference you know we're
not in competition and and in fact I
mentioned Elizabeth Warren at a dinner
that we were going to engage the federal
agencies Treasury start with Treasury
and and education and who else were we
thinking of labor and ash were
engagement with OPM but anyways they all
have raising their hands in fact I got
an email right away from Elizabeth
Warren's office two days later saying we
want to lead the way so so anyway I just
point that out the workplace is a huge
opportunity and all of us here are in
the workplace and can bring it back to
our employ our employers to get that
morning just under said I mean I think
you know obviously the challenges from
the standpoint of both enhancing math
skills and and the challenges of
building financial capability through
our school is absolutely critical but as
somebody who's spent most of us most of
his life in the regulatory side you can
deliver lots of disclosure but if it
isn't delivered at a time when the
person is focused on it when it is a
learning moment it tends to slide right
by one of the great things of the
workplace is your your timing things
with respect to persons who now have a
stake in a variety of ways who are asked
to make decisions from everything from
401ks who are beginning to make that
make judgments with respect to saving
for a home worrying about call education
and the like if if that is a time where
there's Wagram a big way greater
incentives if they provide the infor
information to learn and the other piece
is to get at get at the challenge that
exists in the workplace which is most of
us in the workplace try to make sure and
emphasize how committed we are and with
that that our day job just an exhaust us
from the standpoint of the amount of
time for an employer to say this is
important and it is okay to spend the
time doing it is a critical step in
focusing people at a time when they are
making decisions and that is an
important learning moment and then well
let me just emphasize then picking up on
the trust factor that already mentioned
your research has shown that people
really do trust their employers to do
this so they're not gonna say oh you
know I don't want you know what what's
your angle you know what are you what it
what's this why are you doing this they
actually do want them to do right and I
think since that's a common theme here
you know there's so much curriculum but
where the distribution channels where
people trust so an employee trusts or
employer a non-profit client you know
sapore trust that them you know we trust
our schools some of us you know trust
our government you know so it tends who
you ask but but anyway so yeah it's the
trust factor and distribution channels
and I again it's a it's a big
opportunity I was just going to comment
on one thing though it's interesting in
terms of behaviors so we provide for one
case at Schwab so we have a lot of
research and what this is before
automatic enrollment but we found that
it was people who had one-on-one
consultations that saved twice as much
as those who did not so you asked the
question about technology and it'll see
you know we'll be interesting to see how
technology
compensates for the human interaction
but human interaction is the number one
factor and and I know Ted we all know
analyst Rd who as an expert in this area
in research and she also says
testimonials is one of the second most
important ways to get people to change
behaviors I thought was fascinating just
talking about your story to somebody
else can motivate another person
testimonials from people who have been
through the accessor I you know I wasn't
saving and I'm now you know I took
Vantage of the Schwab 401k and now my
money's grown to axe or you know little
things like that this is also true of
young people by the way the the
thing that I went to last year last
April at the high school in DC the
seminar was being given by a young man
in his 20s who was working for a
financial institution so he was giving
the seminar but he was also telling his
own story which was incredible that at
one point he was literally homeless
living out of his car had no money you
know went out and bummed about 20 bucks
not even 20 bucks to go out and buy some
sponges and soap and a bucket and just
started washing cars on the street made
about $500 enough to chip in for rent to
actually have a home a base an actual
address and then started with some
friends and then started looking for a
job the kids were just open mouths do
you know Gaga listening to this so
anybody who's you know in that age group
or has a story to tell is very
interesting I wanted to add some one
other thing before you leave education
was one other question I wanted to get
to on the subject of curriculum and
teaching kids and math the math question
one thing that I have found is that and
this is kind of sad but the consumer
math classes that are given in schools
are often given to the kids who are sort
of at the lowest academic levels so that
you know if you're in high school and
you're at the upper academic levels
you're getting algebra geometry precalc
AP calculus that sort of thing but if
you're not that you know up at that
level you get the consumer math well it
seems to me that the consumer math is
just as important for the kids them and
the kids and get out and they know me
and they know calculus but they don't
know how to balance a checkbook you know
so it's kind of interesting that that's
the way that when schools do have
consumer math they kind of divide it
like this which is not you know
necessarily I think the best way to go
anyway it's sort of an observation that
I have one of another question that we
got that I thought was rather
provocative it came in two forms it had
to do totally different subject here
regulation and education one question
was can regulation and education should
I poke you in the arm regulation and can
regulation and education be designed to
complement each other okay that was one
question now there was another one
that's a little more provocative it says
much has been owned oh sorry that's a
different question as we move into an
era of dodd-frank and the CFPB which
Carey just mentioned do you
think it's prudent for our government to
continue to move toward legislating away
the fiscal choices of a consumer rather
than promoting consumer fiscal
responsibility so that's kind of an
interesting way of framing your question
it was volunteered the great way about
thing about the Advisory Council it is
apolitical from that standpoint but but
I think the first question is is
extremely valid one I think it was
addressed some in the in the first panel
as well I think absolutely the there is
a coincidence between effective
regulation and and financial education I
you know we as was noted in in the first
panel by Charlie the the range of
financial products becoming ever more
complex I the set of issues from the
standpoint of finding effective ways of
providing disclosure more difficult and
with that along with all the challenges
with respect to dealing with with with
serious and committed and and well
controlled financial providers is the
risk of fraud and it you can't operate
in the regulatory side without
recognizing how important financial
education is from the standpoint of
addressing issues of fraud another
classic example where we worked in a
partnership / carries point working
closely with AARP dealing with with
looking at at the results of some some
financial studies and arrest and
delivering a program throughout the
country with respect to trying to
identify key things to to look towards
for concerns with respect to fraud and
and with that noting that what the most
exposed group is which know isn't women
know isn't minorities it would actually
be white males in their 40s 50s and 60s
guys we've met the enemy and it is us I
the you you can't really address a range
of fraud issues if you if you're just
swinging in and trying to sweep up the
bodies at the end education is a key
piece of trying to ensure a populace
that is more resistant and willing to
ask more
questions willing to recognize it
something something sounds too good to
be true it just is anyway did you want
to say so okay anyone else want to talk
about that okay I think that was very
interesting she this questioner I guess
sees that maybe there's a difference in
obviously we don't you don't necessarily
agree with that between regulating
somehow taking away financial choices
I'm not quite sure what she means by
that perhaps you know people oh how
about this and I just saw a study on
this too we wrote about our magazine
actually people sometimes get lulled
into a false sense of security if
there's a regulation that pertains to a
you know particular subject people get
lulled into a false sense of security
they think oh that's not going to happen
to me I'm not going to be defrauded
because there are laws that protect me
and then I think yeah exactly and then
uh you know so I guess that's perhaps
that's what I think they're probably
referring to the classic concern with
respect to regulation which is a balance
if you put too many restrictions on the
ability to sell products and the costs
involved in selling products you will
reduce choice that the reality I tend to
be a big believer in a combination of
disclosure and oversight while ensuring
that consumers do have choice but choice
has to be in the end a choice across
things that aren't toxic and there are
some products that simply create risk
that that deserve to raise questions of
the whether they should be solved well
we're just about the seven minute mark
of the toward the end of this
presentation and I'm gonna take a little
cue from Maria and at that point what
she did was to ask the panelists what
was you know the takeaways that they
would like to give to the audience I
know I have one of my own but I'm going
to let you folks start first if you
wanted to tell these wonderful people
who have come here and who are listening
in and watching online one thing that
they should know about financial
literacy and how to improve it what
would you say you want to start well I
kind of said this earlier I think the
workplace financial education is a huge
opportunity and I just see this room of
several hundred people who all have an
employer and and I think it's critically
important for us to bring back this
opportunity and also just another side
thing you know I work for a financial
institution I think many of us in this
room do
the majority of our employees do not
understand the basics of personal
finance believe it or not they're not
all brokers in fact probably the brokers
you know there are either like the guys
that we're getting taken in their
fifties I was gonna say that's a
testosterone factor I don't know if that
was politically correct I know men are
more overconfident yeah yeah but anyway
I was just gonna say don't assume that
your employees know the base about
budgeting in fact we did a study of
twenty-something year olds and they all
wished their parents taught them about
savings and budgeting so again that's an
opportunity in all walks of life
including the workplace I just leave
with sort of the you know and we have
many people in this room who are
professionals in this area and they're
not to be preached to but the but to me
the the real challenge in the next phase
is is all about delivery and evaluation
we have a lot of content we have many
many incentives for people who care a
great deal who will continue to develop
very sophisticated content from the
standpoint of financial capability and
financial education what we need to do
first is make sure that that content and
them and the best of that content gets
effectively delivered and that's where
partnerships can happen partnerships
from the schools on through partnerships
with the government and partnerships
with with the the business side all
right the other piece is evaluation we
have a great deal of content it's
equally critical to do the type of work
that Nene does regularly I too demand to
know what works and what doesn't work
all right to be able to drill and drill
down and demand the accountability with
respect to programs as to what they're
actually what the yield is and what
they're actually delivering if we if we
make progress in those two areas I think
we'll have gone a long way Ted I agree
with all of the points were made in the
first panel
and with Kerry and Rick so I'm gonna
take it a little different direction I
asked that same question of a group of
college students last summer and said
okay what's the one thing you've learned
a little variation on what's the one
thing you've learned that's been the
most important component of your keeping
out of financial trouble and these were
not these were students that happened to
be at a meeting I was at they were not
in a class they had nothing to do with
financial education or capability at
that moment and one young woman said
something to me that I've repeated to a
lot of parents who have asked me what
should I do and that is one simple
question if your child asks you what's
how should they figure out financial
issues she said her father had told her
whenever she was thinking about buying
something sleep on it and that then
you're gonna decide overnight where does
this is something you really want or is
it shiny the next day and she said that
kept her out of more financial trouble
that anything she's ever had so I don't
mean to boil it down to one basic thing
but it's talking to your kids and just
getting them to stop and think about
where this fits into their financial
life because I could tell you I'm a
little older than the people at the
table that day and I still do that and
it's kept me out of some really dumb
things you take off on engaged the
parents I think that's where we're
really going with this I was at the
Department of Defense about a week week
and a half ago one of the other areas of
my subcommittee is looking at quite
honestly as the FDIC NCUA Department of
Education partnership that was signed in
November of last year promoting youth
financial education youth access and
youth savings and we went to the
Department of Defense just to discuss
the overseas environment and how the
youth they're becoming a financially
educated and the feedback received by
one of the deputy assistants there was
engaged the parents
we've talked throughout the entire
morning here about financial education
at the school
we've talked about financial education
at the workplace but it all starts at
home
it all starts at home and and if we
don't understand that point then we're
gonna fail because I truly understand
and I recall when my three kids were
growing up and it wasn't me but my wife
is the one that grabbed him by the stack
Israel every so often and just kind of
sat down and gave him the facts of life
on earning spending borrowing protecting
and saving and she did a wonderful job
of that I think if we look at schools as
an extension of our homes and we look at
the workplace as the final end product
of what we've done throughout our lives
then I think you'll really understand
what I'm talking about here so kids
right talk to the kids Carrie's right
you know I wish I'm not sure if it was
Carrie or if it was a Rick that
mentioned but who was it that said wish
my parents had taught me more about
balancing a checkbook in that true and
that's so true so my message to you is
do everything you're doing because
you're doing a fabulous job but engage
the parents in whatever you're doing
because I think that's key and again I
would wrap it up by saying my own wrap
up would be as I said before have
confidence if you're talking to kids
certainly you know more than they do in
basic lessons go a long way and one
corollary everyone's been saying pay
yourself first as a way of no
encouraging saving I would just the
corollary to that is have someone else
do it for you take it off the top so you
don't it doesn't have to burn a hole in
your pocket right join the 401 k plan
get your bank to take off a certain
amount every every month for your
vacation fund or your car fund or
whatever it is do it like that no matter
what your income is that's the only way
people can really save I think and I'd
like to thank our panel here and I think
the one big takeaway for everyone is
that even absent a lot of requirements
that that states have about teaching
financial literacy there are huge
amounts of resources available both in
the classroom in in partnerships that
sort of thing if you need help there are
plenty of places to get it thanks very
much
so Thank You Janet and panelists another
thought-provoking discussion the panel
has left us much to sleep on my
appreciation as well to all of our
attendees both in person and online your
efforts are making a difference in ways
that will pay dividends for generations
to come with that we conclude the summit
and that's around